In this talk.
I want to give you two things.
One, a systematic way to think
about building uncertainty
visualizations.
And, two, a taste
for how to do it.
Using ggdist. ggdist is
an R package that
extends ggplot2 to provide
three additional geometries.
Each of these is a
composite geometry
that uses the same
underlying framework
to understand how to use these.
It's really helpful
to step back and think
about how to
construct uncertainty
visualization systematically.
The idea behind ggdist is that first
you would derive an uncertainty
distribution, and
I don't really care
if you're a Bayesian
or a frequentist,
it doesn't really matter.
The point is you derive an
uncertainty distribution
that you can represent in some
way that ggdist understands,
which might be a
bunch of samples,
it might be a
distributional vector,
it could be a number
of different things.
I'm not going to get
into the details of that.
But if you've derived the
uncertainty of a distribution,
what you can then do is map
distributional properties
onto visual channels, which
is what ggplot kind of calls
aesthetics.
This density plot
you have on the left
might be taking the
density function
and mapping it onto the
thickness of this slab.
And you combine it
with an interval,
which might be, say,
taking two quintiles
and mapping them on to the x-min
and x-max of the interval sub
geometry.
And this is exactly how ggdist
thinks about uncertainty
visualization.
You have stats lab
interval and you're
saying I want to map the PDF.
So the density function onto
the thickness aesthetic,
you can then play around
with different properties,
like maybe the
orientation of this slab
relative to the
interval, you might
decide that you want the
CDF instead of the PDF,
you might decide that
you want a gradient plot.
So you map the
density onto the alpha
instead of onto the
thickness of the slab.
In fact, as of R 4.1 ggdist
supports the true gradients
that have been added
to the graphics engine.
So if you output this
to say an SVG or a PDF,
you can zoom all the way in.
You'll get high
quality gradients
no matter how far you Zoom in.
We can create a whole variety
of different geometries
just from this same slab
interval family.
ggdist provides a bunch
of shortcut geometries,
but they're all really derived
from the same core geometry.
Of course, the dots
interval and line ribbon
are similarly flexible.
You can do a bunch of cool
different things with them,
but I don't really
have time to get
into the details
of how you would do
all of those different things.
On the other hand, I
did promise Twitter
that this talk would be
a Twitter thread directly
into your skull.
So for the rest
of this talk, I'm
just going to jump through a
whole bunch of different fun
examples.
I'm not going to have time to
tell you how to do any of them,
but hopefully it will
wet your appetite
and you might go and try it out.
So let's do this.
All right.
So here's an example of
visualizing a Poisson
distribution using a
distribution vector
from the distributional package.
It knows that it's a
discrete distribution,
so it gives you a histogram
instead of a density plot.
And it also allows
you to, for example,
map the probability
onto the color
so you can get this nice
little gradient effect
speaking of gradients,
here's a gradient plot.
This also shows the use
of the dodge position
from base ggplot with ggdist.
Maybe you decide that you
want to map the CDF onto it.
Actually, this is the
complimentary CDF.
You can think about this
as an infinite number
of bar charts with
infinitesimal opacity
all stacked on
top of each other.
Other things that you
can do with mapping
aesthetics at the
sub-slab level.
So here what we're
doing is we're saying,
oh, there's a particular
region of interest.
Maybe we're interested
in 0 plus or minus 1.5.
So we just map that region
onto a different color,
ggdist subdivides the
geometry and then allows
you to actually map colors
onto subparts of the geometry.
Speaking of subdividing
the slab here,
we're actually using
the CDF function,
essentially bending the CDF
in order to show 50 to 80
and confidence intervals
on the color of the slab.
So this is a nice example of
using PDF and the CDF functions
together in order to
construct a geometry that
would be difficult to do
if you weren't able to use
both of them simultaneously.
Another kind of complex
example of multiple functions
being mapped onto the
slab simultaneously.
The fill color is
actually varying by group.
Then we're using the fill
ramp aesthetic, which
is an aesthetic within ggdist
that allows you to independently
ramp the color to white
as the color gets closer
to 0. Speaking of doing
crazy things with densities,
any probable list
will tell you if you
start taking density functions
and transforminging them
and you have to correct
for the derivative
of the transformation.
Here we have a log,
normal distribution.
We look at it on the raw scale.
It looks like normal.
If you plot this
on a log scale, it
should look like a
normal distribution.
And in fact, it does look
like a normal distribution
because ggdist just
figures out the derivative
and it applies the appropriate
correction to the density.
Everyone loves rain
cloud plots these days.
It just makes them
incredibly easy to create.
So we're just combining
a slab geometry
with a dots interval geometry.
This works because the dots
interval geometry in ggdist
automatically figures
out how big the dots need
to be in order to fit.
This makes it really easy
to combine the dots geometry
with other, more
complex plot layouts.
So here, for example,
this is what some people
call a logic dot plot.
Anyway, I hope that
would convince you
that there's a lot of cool
stuff you can do with ggdist.
I haven't even really
scratched the surface here,
So please give ggdist a try.
And for more of the
examples from this talk,
check out the URL below.